- So let's keep thinking
about different ways
to sit multiple people in
the certain number of chairs.
So let's say we have six people.
We have person A, we have
person B, we have person C,
person D, person E, and we have person F.
So we have six people.
And for the sake of this
video, we're going to say
oh we want to figure
out all the scenarios,
all the possibilities,
all the permutations,
all the ways that we could
put them into three chairs.
So there's chair number
one, chair number two
and chair number three.
This is all review.
This is covered in the permutations video.
But it'll be very instructive as we move
into a new concept.
So what are all the
permutations of putting
six different people into three chairs?
Well, like we've seen before,
we can start with the first chair.
And we can say look if no one's sat--
If we haven't seated anyone yet,
how many different people could
we put in chair number one?
Well there's six different
people who could be
in chair number one.
Let me get a different color.
There are six people who
could be in chair number one.
Six different scenarios for
who sits in chair number one.
Now for each of those six scenarios,
how many people, how many different people
could sit in chair number two?
Well each of those six
scenarios we've taken
one of the six people to
sit in chair number one.
So that means you have
five out of the six people
left to sit in chair number two.
Or another way to think about it is
there's six scenarios of
someone in chair number one
and for each of those six,
you have five scenarios
for who's in chair number two.
So you have a total of 30 scenarios
where you have seated six
people in the first two chairs.
And now if you want to say
well what about for the three chairs?
Well for each of these 30 scenarios,
how many different people could you put
in chair number three?
Well you're still going
to have four people
standing up not in chairs.
So for each of these 30 scenarios,
you have four people who you could put
in chair number three.
So your total number of scenarios,
or your total number of permutations
where we care who's sitting in which chair
is six times five times four,
which is equal to 120 permutations.
Permutations.
Now lemme, permutations.
Now it's worth thinking about
what permutations are counting.
Now remember we care,
when we're talking about
permutations, we care about who's sitting
in which chair.
So for example, for example
this is one permutation.
And this would be counted
as another permutation.
This would be counted
So notice these are all
the same three people,
but we're putting them
in different chairs.
And this counted that.
That's counted in this 120.
I could keep going.
We could have that, or we could have that.
So our thinking in the permutation world.
We would count all of these.
Or we would count this as
six different permutations.
These are going towards this 120.
And of course we have other permutations
where we would involve other people.
Where we have, it could
be F, B, C, F, C, B,
F, A, C, F, F.
Actually let me do it this way.
I'm going to be a little
bit more systematic.
F, uh lemme do it.
B, B, F, C, B, C, F.
And obviously I could keep doing.
I can do 120 of these.
I'll do two more.
You could have C, F, B.
And then you could have C, B, F.
So in the permutation world, these are,
these are literally 12
of the 120 permutations.
But what if we, what if all we cared about
is the three people we're choosing
to sit down, but we don't care
in what order that they're sitting,
or in which chair they're sitting.
So in that world, these would all be one.
This is all the same set of three people
if we don't care which
chair they're sitting in.
This would also be the
same set of three people.
And so this question.
If I have six people
sitting in three chairs,
how many ways can I choose
three people out of the six
where I don't care
which chair they sit on?
And I encourage you to pause the video,
and try to think of what that
number would actually be.
Well a big clue was when we essentially
wrote all of the permutations
where we've picked
a group of three people.
We see that there's six ways
of arranging the three people.
When you pick a certain
group of three people,
that turned into six permutations.
And so if all you want to do is care about
well how many different
ways are there to choose
three from the six?
You would take your whole permutations.
You would take your
number of permutations.
And then you would divide
it by the number of ways
to arrange three people.
Number of ways to arrange,
arrange three people.
And we see that you can
arrange three people,
or even three letters.
You can arrange it in six different ways.
So this would be equal
to 120 divided by six,
or this would be equal to 20.
So there are 120 permutations here.
If you said how many different
arrangements are there
of taking six people and
putting them into three chairs?
That's 120.
But now we're asking another thing.
We're saying if we start with 120 people,
and we want to choose.
Sorry if we're starting with six people
and we want to figure out how many ways,
how many combinations,
how many ways are there
for us to choose three of them?
Then we end up with 20 combinations.
Combinations of people.
This right over here, once again,
this right over here is
just one combination.
It's the combination, A, B, C.
I don't care what order they sit in.
I have chosen them.
I have chosen these three of the six.
This is a combination of people.
I don't care about the order.
This right over here
is another combination.
It is F, C, and B.
Once again I don't care about the order.
I just care that I've
chosen these three people.
So how many ways are there to choose
three people out of six?
It is 20.
It's the total number of permutations.
It's 120 divided by the number of ways
you can arrange three people.